thank you very much for the kind
introduction
and thanks to the organizers for
inviting me it's a great honor and thank
all of you for coming because I know
it's six o'clock you all have a debate
to watch so I promise to to stop at five
so I'm not actually going to talk about
quantum computing all that much so maybe
this will be a relief to some of you I
don't know but I will start by so
quantum computing is really kind of the
motivation for the thing that I'm
talking about so let me start by telling
you what a quantum computer is okay so a
classical computer as you know has a
classical memory which consists of a
number of bits and the bits are
individually addressable so there's like
a fifth bit and the seventh bit and then
the basic operations of a classical
computer are basically to read and write
from this memory and then to perform
logic gates such as and and or you know
and not we think of a quantum computer
as being more similar to a classical
memory chip than to a classical computer
in the sense that it's going to be just
a quantum computer is actually going to
be let's say in this idealized world
just a device that's attached to your
classical computer and on this device
there is some number of quantum bits
also known as qubits okay so I won't
tell you very much about what they are
but they are also individually
addressable so there is cubed zero cubed
one but instead of reading and writing
we have a different kind of basic
operations that we can perform on these
quantum operations the quantum bits and
the basic operations are unitary
transformations and measurement okay so
you imagine you have a classical
computer and then you send instructions
to the quantum device such as apply unit
trans you know apply such-and-such
unitary transformation to qubit number
five or measure qubit number seven okay
so these so these instructions that you
send they are also known as we also call
them gates sort of by analogy with what
happens in in classical computing
now I will not tell you a lot about
quantum mechanics at all but when you
think of a single qubit for the purposes
of this talk you can visualize it as the
spin of a particle okay so even if you
don't know any physics the spin of a
particle is just a vector in
three-dimensional space you could if you
want you could imagine the particle
rotating around an axis or otherwise
it's just just a vector okay so you can
have spin up or spin down or spin can
also point in any other direction in
three-dimensional space okay and a
unitary transformation in that case
corresponds to a rotation of
three-dimensional space for example take
the whole space and rotate it by 90
degrees you know about the z axis that
would map this vector pointing in this
direction to some other vector pointing
in some other direction so you basically
just rotate these these qubits around
quite literally okay so in classical
computing we have classical gates which
are things like and or not and we build
circuits from them these circuits have
inputs and outputs which are classical
bits and even though you only have an or
not given more complex boolean
operations can be implemented in terms
of these gates so you can in fact
implement any boolean function in terms
of N or not gates
that's the completeness of the of the
gate set for classical computing in
quantum computing the quantum computer
manipulates qubits it also has a certain
finite set of built-in gates okay I just
told you that a unitary operation is
some arbitrary rotation of three
dimensional space and in principle there
is not just finitely many of those or
even just infinitely many of those
there's actually uncountably many
different such rotations okay
nevertheless any practical quantum
computer that someone will actually
build will have a finite set of specific
rotations that are sort of built into
the quantum computer this might be
rotations about you know certain fixed
angles for example and these will then
be called the gates of the quantum
computing and many people believe that
when a quantum computer will be built
there will be a particular gate set
built
and that's the so-called Clifford + t
gates that's just a heuristic statement
because you know you could you could use
any sort of finite set of gates but are
not quite any but you can use many
different finite sets of gates but
there's good reasons to believe that
this Clifford plus T gate set is
actually going to be it okay so when you
start designing your quantum software
you might as well assume that that
that's true and the reason that many
people believe this has to do with
quantum error correction so it turns out
in the physics in the actual particles
it's pretty easy to perform some
arbitrary rotation by some arbitrary
angle because these things are done by a
laser pulses okay so you have you have
your qubit somewhere sitting in whatever
physics it's embedded in and then you
send some kind of laser pulse at it and
and the length of the pulse is going to
determine by what angle you've rotated
your qubit so in the physics everything
is continuous because you can
continuously vary the length of these
pulses but it turns out that physical
qubits are incredibly noisy okay so they
need to be err corrected if you don't if
you don't err correct them constantly
then after a few operations you're just
going to have noise and the actual state
of your cubed is going to be lost and
this and it turns out that this error
correction which is the actual error
correction that you do is similar to a
sort of classical error correction like
in the Shannon sense okay so there is a
way I'm not going to tell you how but
there is a way of measuring the noise
without measuring the underlying state
and then you can sort of correct for the
noise without destroying the actual
information and people know how to do
that for the Clifford plus T gate set so
but they don't know how to do it really
for any of the other gate sets so there
is a procedure by which you can take a
single physical by which you can take a
logical qubit and represent it in the
physics by for example seven physical
qubits okay so you built in a bunch of
redundancy and then and then there is a
way of encoding you know a single qubit
into a combined state of the seven and
there is a way
coding it back into a single state but
when you are in the 7 cubed state there
is a way to do the error correction and
it turns out that for these Clifford
plus T gates to perform it what's in
particular true there's a sub I'm going
to tell you what these gates are in the
next slide but there's a subset of them
called the clifford gates and they're
very important because they're
transversal in the error correction okay
that means if you want to perform a
Clifford gate on the encoded cubed then
you perform the same Clifford gate on
each of the seven individual code bits
separately okay
this sort of thing works in classical
codes only with negation typically that
you negate the code word by negating
each bit in the code word in the quantum
world this works for all of these
Clifford gates but they and then the T
gate is not a Clifford gate but people
know how to perform a TV as well so
that's we can take that as a sort of
axiom that the Clifford plus T gate is
is you know probably going to be built
in in this talk we will only focus on a
single qubit so I'm not going to tell
you what a state of two or more qubits
is or what the gates on those ones are
but on the single qubit they you know
let me tell you the names of the gates
okay there is a Clifford gate called H
there's a Clifford gate called s and
then there is this T gate okay and the
best way to explain what they do is
geometrically I already told you that
they correspond to rotations in in
three-dimensional space so here is a
cube okay I put the u c---berkeley logo
on it okay so you can see that I was
especially prepared just for you guys
let's so you know space has some axes
let's say the z-axis points up this
front here is the x-axis and the y-axis
is the green in the middle of the green
face okay so now I can rotate this cube
for example by 180 degrees okay these
Clifford gates that I was just telling
you about actually correspond to
symmetries of this cube so the s gate is
a 90 degree rotation about the z axis
this was an escape
s s s s s to the fourth is equal to the
identity so if you perform the S get
four times that corresponds to four
ninety ninety degree rotations the H
gate is a hundred and eighty degree
rotation about this point here which is
the point halfway between the x axis and
the z axis so that is the H gate
it just swaps the yellow and the white
faces okay of course if you can rotate
about the z axis and you can also swap
the yellow and the white faces then you
can also rotate by 90 degrees about the
x axis how can I make a 90 degree
rotation about the white face well I'm
going to answer my own question so you
just put the white face where the yellow
face was then you do a 90 degree
rotation then then you rotate it back
okay so in other words H s H is a 90
degree rotation about the white face but
then there's another way you can also do
92 rotations about about the about the
blue face as well it's also some
combination of s and H okay now this is
the Clifford group on a single qubit and
as you can see it's finite it only has
exactly 24 elements because these are
the 24 rotations of the cube okay you
can write H shshshsh but it's always
going to be one of these 24 rotations in
the end let me see if I can actually fix
the cube back to its original position
this is a game my children like to play
with this little app so because this is
a finite finite group generated by this
case obviously it's not dense right I
mean there exist some rotations of
three-dimensional space that are not you
know one of these 24 so that's the
reason that you have to add one more nan
Clifford gate and it's the T gate that
we're adding so what does this T gave to
T is actually a square root of s so T is
a 45 degree rotation about the z axis so
45 degree one two three four five six
seven eight so that's it
root of unity right it's T to the 8th is
equal to the identity now now we're also
gonna allow by the same trick as before
if I combine if I do for example H th
then I have a 45 degree rotation about
the white face and if I do sh-t Hsss
then I get a 45 degree rotation about
the green face so let's give ourselves
these this 45 degrees so let's call them
let's call these actually tz4 rotation
about the z axis T sub X for rotation
about the x axis and T sub y for
rotation about the y axis now when you
combine all of these together it's no
longer a finite group in fact if you do
T G sub X Y Z Z Y X you know and a few T
inverses and so on as a matter of fact
this is now this group generated by H s
and T is dense in all of the rotations
of space you can get arbitrarily close
to any place just by performing
sequences of these particular 45 degree
rotations about these particular axes
and it's not difficult to see why it's
dense in fact let's go back to the
identity if you just perform something
like let's say th ok th turns out is
some rotation of space ok every rotation
of 3-dimensional space actually has an
axis of rotation because it always has
an A and an eigenvalue of 1 somewhere so
if you perform th and it turns out it's
a rotation about an irrational angle by
irrational angle I mean some irrational
multiple of 2 pi so that means if I do
th and then th and then th and then th
and then th I can repeat this as many
times as I want but I'm never going to
get back to exactly the identity ok so
I'm rotating basically around some axis
by an irrational angle and if I do that
often enough I can approximate some
arbitrary angle as close as I want ok
and of course when you can do that about
two different axes then it's already
dense in all the in all the rotations so
that's so there that's the universality
of the Clifford plus T gate set in the
same way that an or and not are
universal for boolean circuits clifford
plus T is unit
whistle for for quantum circuits but
it's only up to Epsilon okay you can't
actually you know because you only have
countably many things in that group but
up to epsilon it's it's universal okay
so in fact I said H s and T but it's
much more convenient for our purposes to
use just so these are 90-degree
rotations and 45 degree rotations about
the two different axes by the way when
you do the air I just sort of explained
when you do the error correction doing
an error corrected
Clifford gate is really cheap because
you just have to do say seven separate
Clifford gates one on each physical
qubit by doing an error corrected T gate
is really really expensive the t gate is
approximately a thousand times more
costly to perform than a clifford gate
so for the purpose of counting you know
measuring the sizes of our circuits or
the length of our quantum operations
we're always going to take the T count
as a measure basically we're going to
regard Clifford gates as free and T
gates as you know some unit costs and
the synthesis so I just mentioned to you
that this group is dense in the group of
all rotations of three-dimensional space
the synthesis problem is basically and
find an algorithm that witnesses this
density in other words well there's two
versions the first version is called
exact synthesis here I'm giving you a
three by three matrix which I'm telling
you is actually a member of this group
and that I'm asking you to decompose it
into into a word like sh t sh t h t sh t
okay that's exact synthesis if if the
operator can actually be decomposed
exactly so that's not up to epsilon but
actually on the nose and more important
is the approximate synthesis problem
where you given some arbitrary rotation
of three-dimensional space by any angle
you know any axis whatsoever and you're
given an epsilon and now you have to
find some word in these generators that
brings you within that epsilon after
give an operator okay so that's the
approximate synthesis problem
now here's a I'm supposed to give some
historical remarks okay
so here's sort of a brief history of and
a very very incomplete history I'm
afraid of this problem so basically back
in the 80s some mathematicians the bat
ski Phillips and Saranac proved that
there always exists a word whose length
is on the order of log of 1 over Epsilon
so what's log of 1 over Epsilon right
that's basically the number of digits of
precision that you need so the word that
you need to construct by the way that's
also a lower bound okay so you cannot on
average to any better than or log 1 over
Epsilon so they showed that actually
very short words for example in this
Clifford class he said always exist to
approximate any given thing up to
Epsilon
but the proof that they had in the 80s
is completely non constructive so there
is no algorithm in fact the proof I
believe the proof so the proof uses the
some really deep mathematics ok the
spectral gap of some Hecker operator on
whatever I mean it uses I think both the
Riemann hypothesis and some Ramanujan's
stuff so it's it's like really really
serious mathematics to even prove that
short words exists yet you know within
the given epsilon and there is no
algorithm and in fact up to 2012 the
state of the art for an algorithm for
this problem was the so-called Sala
waked high of algorithm which was
something that was written down it was
invented separately by solavei and
Katara in in the mid-90s
and but this algorithm is not the length
of the words that you get is
significantly longer than the one that's
predicted you know by liubot ski and and
Phillips and saranac so the this is log
to the sea of 1 over epsilon we see I
believe is 3.97 or something like that
or you can fiddle around with the proof
and make
and trade-offs and you but you you can
get you know some C C is always going to
be greater than three and in fact for
the 17 years from 95 to 2012
occasionally some paper came out where
people had reduced the C from three to
two point six seven and then maybe two
point three so you could actually it was
long it was before for this whole time
was an open problem where the C can
actually be reduced to one by an actual
algorithm right as opposed to a non
constructive sort of result
interestingly the problem during these
17 years the problem was considered
extremely difficult it was so difficult
that some people actually proposed to -
some people actually invented a
cryptographic algorithm whose security
was going to be based on the difficulty
of this problem the problem of finding
short words okay and so Charles Garnett
Lauder proposed such a cryptographic
hash algorithm in 2008 and then after
they published it they immediately broke
their own algorithm and showed that it
was not actually secure and but so in
fact the algorithm the family of
algorithms that I'm going to tell you
about today this 2008 one when they
broke the cryptographic hash that was
actually the first that was actually the
first time they sawed off this problem
but they didn't do it exactly in the
setting you know rotations of space
instead of the real numbers and the
complex numbers they used some other
kind of rings like p-adic numbers and so
on
so they proved an analogous thing when
they broke the cryptographic algorithm
in fact in fact they showed already in
2008 that there is an algorithm for
finding short words but no one realized
that that's what they have done and then
in 2012 we actually started applying you
know rediscovering and applying these
number theoretic algorithms so so I'm
emphasizing number theory because the
solloway could have algorithm I was just
telling you but it's based on geometric
ideas when you think of rotations of
three-dimensional space it's extremely
difficult not to think geometrically
right you imagine you have some kind of
a baseball in your hand
and you're rotating it okay and you sort
of want to approximately certain things
you start doing spherical geometry and
so jump you know and in general good
algorithms come from good kind of
mathematics so here this algorithm came
from geometry and now the new class of
algorithms comes from algebraic number
theory so I want to tell you about the
new class of algorithms today but let me
just tell you what the main idea of the
solloway could have algorithm was you
know just to get you primed on how you
sort of how the geometric thinking
actually works it's based on a very
simple idea so imagine I'm standing
somewhere on the surface of the earth
okay facing north and now I'm going to
walk one meter north okay and then one
meter east and then one meter south and
then one meter west okay question did I
arrive at exactly the same point that I
started okay I see one two people
shaking their heads not exactly at the
same point because the earth is actually
curved all right I mean this is the
idealized earth that's curved everywhere
right so this floor is also slightly
curved in fact I arrive very very close
to the point that I started with but not
exactly okay I'm going to be a little
bit off because when I'm one meter
closer to the North Pole then one meter
east is different it's a different
number of degrees as when I'm one meter
further from the North Pole you can also
figure out if there's any places on the
earth where that's not actually true and
moreover the error so how far my
starting point is from my end point is
proportional to the area of this little
square that I walk so if I go two meters
north and then two meters east and then
two meters south and then two meters
west then I actually end fort on you
know approximately four times as far you
know my air will be four times greater
than if I just to one meter okay so that
means so imagine now that you're on some
manifold on a surface basically some
generalized surface and you were walking
some epsilon in one direction epsilon in
this direction epsilon in that direction
and epsilon in this direction then the
actual distance that you've walked is a
proxy
the epsilon squared okay this is the
basic idea of this all awake entire
algorithm the basic ideas if you already
know how to approximate stuff up to
Epsilon
then this little trick a B a inverse B
inverse tells you how to approximate
stuff up to epsilon squared and then you
keep iterating that and your next you
know then you know how to approximate
stuff up to have sine squared you square
it again each time you repeat this trick
you will sort of double the number of
digits of accuracy of something you have
to work out the details you know like in
the right I mean but this is the basic
idea of the algorithm but in fact every
time I've doubled the number of digits
I've also put Drupal the length of the
word and quadrupled is not quite right
so if you do it carefully you figure out
you actually have to do see a be a
inverse B inverse because you want to go
somewhere and then approximate it up to
Epsilon
so every time you double the number of
digits you you multiply the length of
the word by five and you can figure out
that the word is going to be
polynomially longer than it should be
because that's essentially why the C and
what they see the power C in there so we
could have algorithm comes from okay so
number theoretic algorithms so here's
just here's a here's the here's how this
all works however algorithm actually
performs if you want to approximate
stuff up to the area's Epsilon
just to give you some just to put some
numbers on this formula right and the
lower bound is something much smaller as
you can see all right so from now on I
will not basically talk about quantum
computing at all I'll talk about but a
little bit about you know orthogonal
transformations of space and some number
theory so let's do some fun number
theory first really classic number
theory in fact Fermat's theorem on the
sums of two squares it's as classic as
it can get from out published this
theorem in 1750 54 I believe and it's
the answer to the question which
integers can be written as a sum of two
squares for example 5 is equal to 4 plus
1 okay
13 is equal to 9 plus 4 but 7 on the
other hand cannot be written as a sum of
two squares and neither can 21 ok well
we can start we can start with some
simple observations if N and M are
numbers each of which can be written as
a sum of two squares then n times M can
be written as the sum of two squares do
you see this immediately probably not
but you could do a calculation on an
envelope and come up with a formula you
know for the for the thing but it turns
out it's actually much easier if we
think about complex numbers so if a and
B are integers then a squared plus B
squared is equal to a plus bi times a
minus bi right and when you write it in
this form it's an immediately obvious
that if two numbers are at this form
then their product is of this form right
because they each you know if you write
T for the complex number then n times M
is just a product of products and
therefore itself a product basically of
a number and it's complex conjugate of
course a and B are integers right so
these are the Gaussian integers that I'm
talking about complex numbers of the
form a plus bi where a and B are
integers and so the first lesson of
number theory is we learn a lot more
about the integers by moving to a bigger
ring for example the Gaussian integers
it's easier to see what the formulas are
what about the converse is it also true
that if n times M can be written as a
sum of two squares then N and M
separately can be written as atomic sum
of two squares the answer is no in
general for example forty-nine can be
written as zero plus 49 but 7 we already
saw cannot be written as a sum of two
squares right but if N and M are
relatively prime meaning they do not
have any prime factors in common then
it's true okay if N and M are relatively
prime and n times M has this property
then do then so do n and how do you see
this
well here's here's basically here's the
proof okay so suppose n times M can be
written as a sum of two squares so we
already know that we should look at the
gaussian integers and we should write it
in this form then basically what you do
is if you look at the prime so it turns
out the gaussian integers are euclidean
domain that means in the gaussian
integers you can take greatest common
divisors and least common multiples you
can compute division with remainder and
you can take greatest common divisors in
in the gaussian integers just like in
the ordinary integers and that also
means that in the gaussian integers
every Gaussian integer uniquely factors
into a product of Gaussian Prime's okay
just like every ordinary integer factors
into a product of ordinary Prime's
uniquely so basically you look at the
prime decomposition of n times m in the
Gaussian integers and you find out that
each of these Prime's either goes into
this factor or into this factor and
that's basically the whole idea of the
proof so you take the greatest common
divisor of N and a plus bi and the
greatest common divisor of m and a plus
bi and then the easy argument about the
prime factorization shows that both N
and M have separately written as a
Gaussian integer times its conjugate so
the second lesson of number theory is
that it's really useful when the when
the rings that we're looking at are
Euclidean domains so that we can do
greatest common divisors in them okay
prime factorizations so because of these
two properties it follows that to decide
whether a given integer can be written
as a sum of two primes or not it's a as
a sum of two squares or not sorry
it's sufficient to consider when the
integer is a prime right because when
it's not a prime I can just write it as
a product as before okay and answer the
question separately for each of the
factors so which Prime's can be written
as a sum of two squares well here's a
list of the first first twenty Prime's
all right two and five and 13 for
example can be written as a sum of two
squares but no matter how hard you try
19 or 11 cannot okay so what is the
pattern here this is the pattern that
firma recognized you have to look at at
your number is module 4 okay look at
what your Prime's are module 4 2 is 2
modulo 4 and every other prime is odd so
it's either 3 or 1 modulo 4 and it turns
out the Prime's that are congruent to 1
modulo 4 can be written as a sum of two
squares and the Prime's that are
congruent to 3 modulo 4 cannot and it's
very it's very easy to see that second
part why can a number that's congruent
to 3 modulo 4 never be written as a sum
of two squares because every square is
either a square of an even number or an
odd number if you're despair of an even
number then you're congruent to 0 modulo
4 and if you square of an odd number
then you're congruent to 1 modulo 4 so
if so and and and you can't add
something that's 0 of 1 to something
that's 0 or 1 and get a 3 ok that's not
possible
and the second part I'm going to not
give you the proof of the other one but
it's also not very difficult ok again it
has to do with the the Gaussian integers
and again we use the fact that we can
take greatest common divisors in there
moreover so from I'd prove this 250
years ago moreover there is an efficient
probabilistic algorithm to compute a and
B so if I give you a very very large
prime you know ten thousand digit prime
that's congruent to one modulo four I
can actually efficiently compute an A
and a B so that any or P is equal to a
squared plus B squared the algorithm is
probabilistic but only a little bit okay
there is something that you have to do
in the algorithm which succeeds with
probability exactly 50% and then you
just have to repeat it a couple times
until you find the answer that that
you're looking for and as a corollary we
have this property for Prime's
as a corollary given any n we can
efficiently decide whether n is equal to
a squared plus B squared and find the a
and B provided that we have a prime
factorization of n if I have the prime
factorization of n then I can just use
the previous lemmas and do you know and
just answer the question basically
separately for each prime factor if I
don't have a prime factorization of n
then answering this question is probably
as hard as as finding a prime
factorization of n I'm not sure if
that's actually yeah theorem or just you
know a heuristic I think it's probably
close to being a theorem if you can if
you can compute the answer to this
question for arbitrary n then you can
also factor so that's actually a hard
problem but once you have factored and
then then the rest of it is an easy
problem by the way such equations are
called Diophantine equations equations
where the solutions are supposed to be
integers like this one called eiephant
in equations that we're going to and and
the you know basically the lesson
learned is dire Fantini equations are
easy to solve once you know how to
factor ok it's not true for all
Diophantine equations but it's going to
be true for all the ones that we're
going to encounter in my talk today ok
second bit of fun sort of number theory
this is great problems so in so what are
the gaussian integers really we have
taken the ordinary integers and then
we've added the number i okay
what is the number i it's a square root
of -1 now we could say what happens if
instead of a square root of -1 we add
another kind of square root for example
the square root of 2 okay
so consider all real numbers of the form
a plus B root 2 where a and B are
integers that's also a ring because you
can add and subtract and multiply two
such numbers and you immediately see
that they're again of this form and just
like the complex numbers it also has a
kind of conjugation you know how you can
take the complex conjugate of a number
means replace I by minus I and if you
take the square root to complement of a
number it means replace the square root
of two by negative of the square root of
two
right because minus square root of two
is also a square root of two
this is actually an auto morphism of the
Ring meaning that it's this this bullet
operation which swaps the sign in front
of the square root is compatible with
addition subtraction and multiplication
okay and moreover if you take some
element of this if you take some number
of this form and multiply it by its own
bullet you always get an integer which
is called the norm of alpha and it's
equal to a squared minus 2v squared all
right they said that root 2 which is the
set from the previous side of integers
of the form a plus B over 2 it's dense
in the real numbers as you can see in
this picture but I can sort of pull it
apart into a look did you see this
here's a dense set but you can you can
just sort of pull it apart into a square
and then it's no longer dense ok so each
number if I write the real number line
diagonally each point you know each each
point of this grid here projects onto a
point on the diagonal line and when you
look at all of them of course it's dense
but when you look at this picture it
gives you a lot more information than
this picture all right like I mean you
actually see you don't see anything in
this picture because it's just black
right so we can in some sense think of
that root 2 as a discrete set rather
than a continuous set and that turns out
to be very useful and an interesting
thing is I can also take the same grid
and project it onto the opposite
diagonal I get another dense subset of
the real line and that's exactly the
remember the bullet operation from the
previous slide which we faced square
root of 2 by minus square root of 2 well
if you take any point here and then you
pull it out into the grid and then you
project it onto the other coordinate
that's exactly the same as the bullet
operation because the coordinate down
there would be a minus P root 2 and I
would like to point out that this is not
an even grid this is not a square grid
right because the distance from here to
here is 1 and the distance from here to
here is square root of 2 so this would
be square root of 2 plus 1 for example
all right grid problems so these are the
kind of problems that we will have to
solve
consider the following strange thing
give me a subset of the real numbers
like think of an interval okay like this
green interval here now we're going to
say the grid of the set B is the set of
all those numbers after form a plus B
root two such that the bullet of that
number is in the green set okay
for example this number here is 1 plus
square root of 2 and it's been marked
because 1 minus square root of 2 is an
element of the green set ok this number
here is 2 plus square root of 2 and it's
it's been marked as being on the grid
because 2 minus square root of 2 is in
the green set but then of course and
here I have 2 plus 2 or 2 and so on so
this so these black dots form the grid
that's sort of dual to the green set now
the green set is sort of complete the
green set is compact or Addison it's an
interval it's very short but but the the
black set is always discreet in fact
there is a minimum distance always
between between these between
consecutive points and it's also
infinite and it's quasi periodic okay
what does quasi periodic mean it's not
quite periodic but any if you take any
if you take any interval of the black
points finite size then you will find
infinitely many copies of that exact
pattern you know everywhere along the
set so you've seen quasi periodic sets
before because these Penrose tilings
right Roger Penrose gave these beautiful
tilings with kite blew up and there's
some other things starting up you've
probably seen these the kite and dagger
tilings and so on they are in symmetries
of 5 ok these are another example of
quasi periodic
all right so that's what a grid is by
the way if I make the green set bigger
then the black set also gets bigger that
means it's just going to get more points
on it so bigger in that sense means
denser okay the great problem is give me
2 intervals of the real numbers a green
one and a red one and now take the grid
of the green set and find find all the
find all the grid points of the green
set that are members of the red set okay
so find the intersection of a with the
grid of B or equivalently find all the
points alpha from the bring such that
alpha is in a and alpha bullet is in B
we call that a one dimensional grid
problem and it turns out in many cases
it's easy to solve so let's go back to
the picture that I had before of my zero
to set where I had written a on the
x-axis and B on the wire be root 2 on
the y-axis then if I have a if I have an
element alpha of my ring to say that
it's in the interval a means that its
projection to the diagonal is in the
interval a so that's the same as to say
that the point lies somewhere between
these two co diagonal lines so the
requirement that a plus B root 2 isn't
is a member of the set a just means that
the point has to lie between two
parallel lines and the requirement that
the element isn't that the the
requirement that a bullet is a is a
member of P means that the point has to
lie between these two lines okay
so finding a solution to the 1
dimensional grid problem is the same as
finding the points inside a skewed
rectangle of this other grid which was
the which was the sort of integer grid
that we were looking at before and it's
clear that it's going to be easy to find
such solutions provided that the
rectangle is big enough for example if
its width and height are at least 2 then
you can always find a point in there and
it's very easy to do you just compute
the coordinates of this point and you
compute the coordinates of this point
that gives you an interval and the x
axis you try every possible integer in
and above that integer you will maybe
find a solution okay if there is one but
there is a difficult case namely if your
rectangle is very very long and very
very thin so if the set a is if the red
set is very small and the green set is
very big then you can have the situation
where you have a very long and skinny
rectangle and it's like shooting through
space on a starship and wondering if
you're going to hit a star okay
the your trajectory is very thin and the
stuff that the stars are relatively far
apart so you know it looks like there
might be a solution here maybe but it's
not clear how we could guarantee that we
would find a solution in such a set but
there is a nice sort of trick of number
theory so this is lesson three of number
theory which is use the units of the
ring what does that mean 1 plus square
root of 2 times 1 minus square root of 2
is equal to what 1 plus root 2 times 1
minus root 2 is equal to minus 1 okay so
that means that's an invertible element
that means if you multiply something by
let's call this num this number lambda
if if you multiply an element of this
wing by lambda then you can undo this
later by sort of unmultiplied it or just
multiply by the inverse of lambda right
which is root 2 minus 1 so
multiplication by lambda maps this
entire grid here to itself and what it
also does it turns out when you apply it
to one of these rectangles what
did--what multiplying by lambda also
does is it will shrink the rectangle in
one dimension and simultaneously make it
fatter in the other dimension so let's
so the grid the grid problem for a and B
is equivalent to the great problem for
lambda times a and lambda bullet times B
use the use the animation right you
multiplied by lambda once twice ok and
the area of the rectangle stays the same
but you can just make the skinny part
fatter and the fat part skinnier and in
the end you have a rectangle with
approximately equal proportions and then
you can already efficiently enumerate
the the solutions in there ok
that's an interesting technique called
scaling ok now here you can now see very
clearly that they're exactly three
solution
one two three okay if you go back and
these three solutions are actually in
one-to-one correspondence with the
previous solution so here's one two
three and here is one two three okay so
the scaling trick doesn't actually
change your set of solutions it just
transforms your problem into one that's
easier to solve and therefore we have an
algorithm for efficiently solving one
dimensional grid problems all right now
I'm gonna skip this I'm not going to
tell you really about the two
dimensional grid problems let me just
tell you what we just did with a set a
and B on the number line we can also do
this in the plane okay instead of the
Rings Etro - we're going to use a
different ring called Z Omega which
which is which is a subset of the
complex number this rings that Omega is
like that root 2 but it's a subset of
the complex numbers instead of the real
numbers and then you can say you know
now this time your green set and the red
set will actually be subsets of the
plane and again they will generate
certain grids and again we can solve you
know we can formulate and solve the
2-dimensional grid problems by a very
similar method that I just showed you in
the one-dimensional one okay so sorry
yeah I want to just I didn't think these
slides would be there I thought I had
already deleted them all right ok so
let's get back to the to the problem at
hand now that we've done a little bit of
number theory okay a rotation of
3-dimensional space can also be written
as a matrix where you write in each cup
you you basically you can write sorry I
don't know what those I have no idea
what these betas are doing here because
these are supposed to be 1 over square
root of 2 I think something got messed
up with my with my slides here so you
can write a rotation of 3-dimensional
space as a matrix okay and these are the
matrices
falling to 90 degree and 45 degree
rotations respectively if beta is equal
to 1 over square root of 2 and let's go
back to the Clifford plus T group that
we were talking about so it's generated
by these six matrices here the
connection between that and the ring I
was just talking about is that every
element here is of the form something
divided some integers divided by the
square root of two okay so it turns out
when you multiply these matrices
together all the entries that you're
going to get are going to be of this
form basically a plus B over two a and B
are integers divided by some power of
square root of two and so you get a set
of matrices with this property and it's
very remarkable that the converse is
also true okay
every 3x3 matrix with that's you every 3
by 3 orthogonal matrix whose elements
are of this form is a member of the
Clifford plus C group ok so that means
we have a completely mathematical
description of the Clifford pasta group
now just referring to the to the entries
of the matrix right rather than
referring to generators and with this we
can go quite far so this is the theorem
it's the if and only if and moreover the
T count the number of T generators that
you actually need to write that matrix
is exactly equal to this K here it's
exactly the smallest sub K for which the
number can be written in this in this
way is exactly equal to the tea cup ok
so another fact is every Clifford plus T
operator can be uniquely written in this
form a bunch of 45 degree rotations and
then a Clifford operator at the very end
and such that no consecutive 2t sub i's
are equal so it could be for example T X
T YT X T YT Z but not T X T X because
that would cancel out to an S and then
you could move it to the very right okay
and it's it's quite remarkable that this
normal form is also unique
okay so that means I showed you the
picture before right the graphic of
rotating stuff by 45 degrees and how it
was tense but another way to think about
this same process is that you're walking
around on a graph this is an infinite
regular graph each vertex has three
neighbors
okay labeled XY and z and then you know
you perform a 45 degree rotation 45
degree rotation 45 degree rotation it
corresponds to a path to a unique path
somehow on this graph and effectively
what we've done by using these gates for
the unit for the for the for the
rotations is we've essentially taken a
sphere and wrapped this graph here
around it imagine taking us here and
kind of wrapping it in this graph okay
and if you keep doing this you will get
densely you know you will approximate
every point but of course usually if you
want to get to a nearby point it's like
having a bunch of railway stations that
are very far apart but dense okay so to
get from this point to a nearby point
you might have to take a very very long
path to get there all right and in fact
the closer you want the point to be the
longer the path that you will have to
take will be so that's why the problem
was considered difficult okay
now I'm going to cheat you all by just
giving I can't really give you the
details of the other algorithm that's
not really possible but I will give you
just the flavor of it okay
we will apply a really nasty trick top
of mathematicians apply which is instead
of orthogonal 3x3 matrices I'm going to
swap goals and I'm going to talk about
complex two-by-two matrices and then I'm
just going to say that they're
essentially the same thing okay so once
we have the complex two-by-two matrices
we're only going to approximate diagonal
ones that means in our previous picture
that would correspond to rotations about
the z-axis only but by some arbitrary
angle but only about the z-axis if you
can do three of those then you couldn't
do an arbitrary rotation and then we're
going to approximate this by matrix by
matrices of that form where you and T
are from a certain ring and the strange
fact is that the error only
on you and not tea and then we get and
now I'm going to pull the fast one on
you right it turns out that it's an easy
calculation that shows for this
approximation to be good
ie less than or equal epsilon is
equivalent to the number you living in a
certain region of the unit circle and
the region takes the form of a meniscus
you've probably heard of a meniscus
because it's something you have in uni
ok but the the actual shape of a
meniscus is what happens when you take a
sphere and you just slice off a piece so
it's flat on one side and sort of curved
on the other so a 2-dimensional meniscus
is this kind of region here that you get
by almost taking a tangent like you're
just slicing up a little piece of circle
okay and they and the width of this
thing here is approximately epsilon
squared so it can be very very thin and
now we have to find and we have to know
so the prior I'm telling you without
proof that the problem of finding the
finding the good approximations now
reduces to two things finding a suitable
element you in this region here that's a
great problem so we already know how to
solve it and then solving the equation
that t square plus u squared equals 2 to
the K which is the Diophantus equation
so we already know how to solve it so
strangely the problem can be decomposed
exactly into the two things I was
telling you about a great problem and it
I found an equation and the reason that
this works is completely magical ok
there's I don't know any you know deeper
reason but it just works and then we're
done okay we know how to do both and
therefore we're done and now we have an
algorithm which given a rotation about
the z axis and an epsilon and given my
ability to factor Diophantus my ability
to solve that I found in equations which
means as I told you we have to be able
to factor integers if I can factor
integers then I now have sort of
described an algorithm that will
actually not only be O of log of 1 over
epsilon as was predicted you know
already in the 80s but it's actually up
so this is a really strong algorithm of
all the possible clifford plus T
sequences that are going to get you into
this epsilon ball the algorithm will
actually find the shortest one all right
not just oh oh off the shortest one or
approximately the shortest one it will
find their very shortest one so it
cannot be any better than that right and
that's only if I can factor though
because I need that to solve my dear
Fantine equations it turns out factoring
is hard but not really right factoring
is hard only in the worst case if I give
you like the two thousand digit RSA
challenge you're not going to be able to
fact without probably but factoring a
random number is actually not that hard
if I gave you one thousand two thousand
digit numbers okay each chosen randomly
within a certain range then the
probability that you could factor at
least one of them is actually
exceedingly high in fact the probability
that one of them is a prime is already
very high so factoring factoring any
number is not is not easy but factoring
a random number is not in general hard
so the point here is what's required for
this algorithm is essentially to factor
a random number because you find these
candidate solutions and if one of them
you can't factor you just move on to the
next one so we saw this so these sort of
number theory algorithms are optimal if
you if you can factor but even if you
cannot factor there nearly optimal so
it's o of 1 over sorry its log of log of
1 over Epsilon away from being optimal
so that does log of log of 1 over
Epsilon is usually less than 30 okay so
here is what this Alava could hire up
algorithm does here is the lower bound
short solution you could have for the
given epsilon and here's what the
algorithm I just described actually
finds when you don't have access to
factoring so you can see for small
numbers it's still optimal because
hundred digit numbers are easy to factor
and when you get to larger numbers it's
off by a few okay so
this work that I just described was done
between 2012 and 2014 I would say and
this is what sort of the first number
theoretic algorithm for solving this
problem for the Clifford plus T gait
said and in the years what has only been
two or three years but in the in the
years since then people have applied the
same sort of idea to other gait sets
other than Clifford plus T so so there
is now a whole industry of finding
similar short approximations for other
kind of gates to examples of fibonacci
gates and Clifford has to be which part
you know other gates head stuff could be
error corrected maybe one day so this is
the end here are some references oh and
I'm not the very end though because I
just wanted before you all go to watch
the debate on TV I just want to actually
show you like when I say the algorithm
is efficient give me an angle any angle
sorry 12 degrees so that would be 12
times pi over 180 right I have to put
this in quotes because it's the shell
and to hop to what apps let's say let's
first do this to 50 decimal digits okay
so here's the operator that was
efficient epsilon is equal to 10 to the
minus of 50 that's your actual angle and
this is the actual operator expressed in
terms of SH and T and maybe a Clifford
operator at the end okay
now this this algorithm can go up to 10
to the minus 2,000 and it would still
give you the answer in less than an hour
and that's not even a supercomputer
that's just this laptop here right so
that's just the they say the proof is in
the pudding right these algorithms are
fantastically fast and and you can even
see the you can ask it to actually show
you the matrix like that that's the
actual matrix of course written with
some incredibly large integers in it but
it will also compute the actual error
which in this case was 0.98 bla bla bla
times 10 to the minus 50 so we asked for
the error to be less than 1
10 to the minus 50 and it and then it
computes the air sort of after the fact
right to make sure there wasn't some bug
in the algorithm so anyway on this note
I will send you all off and see if you
have any questions thank you very much
ah yes
so I remember that our algorithm
factored into two pieces first I had to
solve a grid problem for a small as
possible case so that the T count would
be smallest and then I had to solve it I
found an equation to solve the die
Fantine equation I have some incredibly
large integer and I'm going to have to
try to factor it it turns out I try to
factor it not very hard because in some
it's often more efficient to just move
on to the next integer than spending a
lot of time trying to factor the one and
what this tells you is where was it so
here that means 19 candidates were tried
13 of them the algorithm could prove
that the Diophantus equation didn't have
a solution so it was able to factor the
integer but unfortunately there was no
solution five of them timed out so it
couldn't tell if the diaphragms in
equation had a solution or not because
it couldn't factory the integer and one
succeeded and when that happens then you
have then you have an answer so if the
number if the number timed out is equal
to zero
then you probably have found the
shortest solution if the number timed
out is five then the solution that you
have found might be the sixth optimal
solution in the worst case they could at
most be five better solutions so so in
fact not only do you get close to with
an optimal but you actually sort of know
how close to within optimal you got yes
yep
so on the numbers up to ten to the end
there's approximately one in n of them
is prime
the largest prime factor could be that
well the number could be prime if it's
not prime so the smallest prime factor
oh I'm not sure what you're asking I
mean so usually what happens is that you
find a couple of small factors 2 3 5 you
know those are pretty common and then
after you remove those either the rest
of your number is prime or else you just
give up and move on to the next number
that turns out to be actually in fact we
find factors up to up to about a hundred
digits because it's easy to find those
with with some polar draw method or
something but if we saw we find all the
factors up to a hundred digits and if
we're lucky enough then the rest of the
rest of the number will just be one
large prime and in fact if it's not then
we're in one of those cases where it's
gonna be timed out yes
so finding the closest vector on some
arbitrary integer lattice is a hard
problem but finding the intersection of
an integer lattice and a convex set
turns out not to be a hard problem so by
the by the by similar scaling trip trick
as the one I've shown you you can always
map the integer lattice to itself in
such a way that your convex set gets
appropriately fat and once so once you
have a ball in the convex set then it's
easy to find the solutions so that's
basically the famous Lal Lenstra lens
try and something algorithm I forgot
what the third L stands for I think two
of them are lens tours right Novak's
lens trailer box and I think again lens
try right
so it allows you to find that's actually
effectively what we're using here
finding the intersection of a convex set
and integer grid the difficult part is
when the origin is not an element of
yourself sorry the difficult part is
when the origin is an element of you set
because then you can't prove it's the
only one
yes so
yeah so the question is I'm just
repeating it because not being recorded
I should have repeated you raised this
question too the question is what
happens with multiple qubits and the
answer is there's already a method where
you could there's already a method of
taking any unitary operator on n qubits
and decomposing it quite efficiently
just into seen arcades and single qubit
operators so if you know how to
approximate single qubit operators up to
epsilon over N then you know how to
approximate n cubed operators up to
epsilon basically and it turns out there
is basically not known any more clever
method than what I just said you can do
more clever things but they usually end
up giving you longer circuits so they're
not so clever in the end
any other questions